monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le président de la délégation entre mr
chers collègues mesdames messieurs les
élus pêche aquaculture activités
portuaires transport maritime tourisme
maritime
exploration des fonds marins le champ de
l'économie bleus en outre-mer est
presque infini pourtant malgré ses
nombreuses potentialités les activités
maritimes ne représente en outre-mer
qu'un peu plus de 2% de l'emploi
marchand et qu'un peu moins de 4 % du
tissu entrepreunarial marche face à ce
paradoxe
il nous faut apporter des réponses sont
viser l'exhaustivité
je me concentrerai sur trois points la
situation du secteur portuaire et du
transport maritime celle de la pêche et
de l'aquaculture et enfin les enjeux
d'exploration et d'exploitation des
fonds marins le commerce maritime
représente aujourd'hui près de 90% du
commerce mondial avec leur situation
privilégiée qu'il aimait à proximité des
grands noms des grandes routes maritimes
les ports ultra marins peuvent jouer un
rôle essentiel et en tirer des
opportunités pour l'emploi et le
développement des territoires dans la
diversité de leurs statuts grand port
maritime port autonome port d'intérêt
national ces porcs est cependant encore
trop tourné vers le seul trafic hexagone
outre-mer au détriment du réseau
régional et international
l'enjeu pour nos ports ultramarins est
d'en faire de véritables hubs régionaux
un exemple à suivre en la matière est
celui de port réunion qui a su investir
pour devenir le hub du sud de l'océan
indien notre étude devra s'attacher à
analyser ce succès et en comprendre les
ressorts pour sont inspirés pour les
autres bassins maritimes une des clés de
cette réussite est probablement à
trouver dans la modernisation des
infrastructures portuaires qui doivent
s'adapter à l'explosion du trafic par
conteneurs appelé à tripler d'ici 2035
le port de demain ne sera probablement
plus seulement un site logistique mais
gagnera à mobiliser son fonciers pour
regrouper une pépite hier d'entreprise
maritime notre étude devra par ailleurs
veiller à la déclinaison concrète pour
les outremers des objectifs de
numérisation et de verdissement des pans
fixés par la stratégie nationale
portuaire de 2021 je n'oublie pas non
plus un sujet brûlant d'actualité celui
de l'explosion du coût du fret maritime
sur lequel il nous faudra apporter des
solutions j'en viens maintenant aux
enjeux de l'aquaculture et de la pêche
notre production aquacole est encore
trop limite outre-mer elle s'établit
autour de 2000 tonnes constitué à 80%
par l'élevage de crevettes en nouvelle
calédonie ce secteur attire peu de
nouveaux producteurs et manque de
structuration tout particulièrement en
matière de formation
s'agissant de la pêche vous le savez un
des enjeux majeurs concernent les aides
européennes à la modernisation et au
renouvellement de la flotte en principe
l'union européenne interdit les
subventions à l'augmentation des
capacités de pêche mais une exception a
été prévu pour les rup et les conditions
sont cependant tel que ces fonds n'ont
pas pu être mises en oeuvre il ya là un
chantier à poursuivre qui avait déjà été
mis en avant par l'étude de la
délégation sur les enjeux européens pour
les outre-mer en 2020 au delà de la
préservation nos activités
traditionnelles
il nous faut également préparer les
filières de demain et encourager la
diversification des activités et les
innovations la tenue des premières
assises économique des outre-mer début
décembre devrait participer à ce travail
prospectif j'en termine avec le défi de
l'exploration des fonds marins grâce au
programme extraplac la france a étendu
depuis 2015 sans domaine maritime de
plus de 700 mille kilomètres carrés
supplémentaires
que faire de cette extension et plus
particulièrement que faire des
ressources des fonds marins dont nous
disposons dans les eaux ultramarine à
quelles conditions et à quelle échéance
pourra-t-on passé de l'exploration à
l'exploitation avec le plan france 2030
les ambitions sur l'exploration des
fonds ont été réaffirmés et des
investissements sont prévus pour une
meilleure compréhension du vivant dans
ces zones comme l'a rappelé ma collègue
annick petrus les innovations pouvant
être tirés des fonds marins sont
nombreuses en termes de recherche
médicale ou d'applications technologies
je pense notamment aux dieux métalliques
ou en croûte manquons balti faire aux
amas sulfurés qui sont des ressources
riches en minéraux qui peuvent pallier
l'épuisement des terrains la france a la
chance de disposer d'opérateur
historique en la matière que peu de pays
détiennent le premier d'entre eux étant
l'ifremer il faudra nécessairement
rester prudent et attendre la la fin des
campagnes de recherches qui doivent
mesurer les impacts des programmes
d'exploitation d'exploration sur les
possibles déstabilisation du milieu
marin nous ne pouvons cependant pas
faire l'impatience et ressources il nous
faut anticiper en préparant l'écosystème
économique de nous outre-mer à ses
potentialités ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui voilà messieurs président
mesdames messieurs les élus de nombreux
sujets de réflexion dessinée en quelques
rapides perspectives de notre étude en
cours et que nous souhaitions partager
avec vous merci